- Hey out there, welcome in.
Welcome, welcome, welcome
to another exciting ravishing
edition of "Market Takes."
Listen, I know you could have
been anywhere in the world,
but you are right here
with me on "Market Takes."
I appreciate that.
I'm your host, Dion Rabouin,
reporter at the Wall Street Journal.
Listen, there is a lot going
on out there in the world.
We are bringing you the three big things
that you need to be
watching out for this week.
We're gonna tell you what those are,
why they matter and why it's meaningful
to the market, the economy,
all that good stuff.
So listen, first,
we are fully into earning
season at this point,
but we have a big week this week,
a lot of big tech names
reporting, some banks.
We've got a big mix
and we're gonna tell you
all about what's happening
and tell you what the most
important earnings reports are
to watch out for in terms
of what that can mean
for the market to investors
and overall to the economy big picture.
Second, we get the first
look at US first quarter GDP.
If you remember this time last year,
people weren't really
talking about the GDP report.
Then it came in negative, was
wildly unexpected, much lower,
and that led to a lot of concerns
that the US was already in a recession.
Those fears have kind of abated,
but this first quarter GDP report
comes with a lot of questions.
We are gonna get that
and that's gonna answer
a lot of questions about the economy.
Third, we get two major reports,
the two major reports
on consumer confidence
and sentiment this week.
I'll tell you what those are,
what to look out for in each of those.
So without much further
ado, let's get into it.
Earnings.
Listen, we've already
kicked things off this week.
This morning, we found
out that Credit Suisse
lost more than $68 billion last week
or last quarter, excuse me.
That was more than expected.
They also borrowed more from
Central Bank liquidity backstop
than had been originally thought.
Basically, that just means
that Credit Suisse was in more trouble
than we expected, than what we thought.
Writing down a lot of that debt,
that highlights some of the
challenges ahead for UBS.
Remember UBS acquired Credit Suisse
in that kind of last
minute, last second deal,
where they acquired it with
help from the Swiss government.
That was a big deal
and this now looks like,
man, things could be even worse for UBS.
Maybe Credit Suisse and those bad assets
dragged down UBS more than worried about.
I wanna read a quick quote
here from some analysts at KBW.
They said, quote, "The revenue
trajectory is so damaged
that the deal could well remain a drag
on UBS operating results
until a deeper restructuring
plan is announced."
All that means is there
could be more trouble
maybe now at the bigger banks.
We heard from some of
those big banks last week,
they look good.
JP Morgan Chase, if you remember,
$52 billion in profits,
big numbers, big names.
So a lot of those big banks could be
in solid condition over here in the US.
But then you look over there at Europe,
well maybe there are bigger problems.
Keep that in mind.
We are gonna hear this week
from First Republic Bank.
Now if you're familiar with that name,
you're like, "Why have I been
hearing about First Republic?"
It's because that's
really been the subject
of a lot of targeting.
The stock has just been plummeting,
falling off a cliff for a while
and it's been one of those banks
that investors have been
worried about for some time.
It's stock price has tumbled,
its market value has tumbled.
We are gonna hear from them
what actually happened at the bank,
how are they holding up?
And that'll be a big piece
of this overall bank picture.
We're gonna talk about
that in just a minute.
There have been some big
winners and big losers overall
from these earnings reports already.
Last week, we heard from Western Alliance
that said outflows, they lost
a lot of money in deposits,
but that stabilized
and they actually rose $2 billion
at the end or at the first half of April.
That stock up 24% last week.
Metropolitan Bank deposits fell 3%,
but they kind of chalked
that up to crypto losses
less than expected.
Stock rose 15% for the week.
On the other side of that,
some big losers, Truist Bank,
another one of those kind
of regional behemoths
that was created by the
combination of BB&T and SunTrust.
Deposits down 5% from a year earlier
and down 2% from the previous quarter.
That stock was down 5% for the week.
KeyBank, another one of
the bigger regional banks,
deposits down 3% from a year earlier
and down 1% from the previous quarter.
Those shares were down 5% last week.
So while you did see some stocks
do better than expected or some banks,
really the overall mood from investors
was still negative on the banking sector.
And I wanna put a chart
up here on your screen
that really kind of tells us
what's so important
about this earnings week.
Now the line you see up there at the top
that's skying above all the rest,
that's the NASDAQ 100.
That's those big tech names.
You're talking Meta,
you're talking Amazon,
you're talking Microsoft.
All those big, big huge masses,
some of the biggest country,
some of the biggest companies, excuse me,
in the US overall, that's what that is.
And we've seen investors move
into those big tech names
and out of some of the others.
That's why it's doing so much better
than the S&P 500 so far this year
because investors are really
just seeking out the safety
or at least the supposed safety.
It seems a bit like an oxymoron, right?
Because tech is generally
thought of as risky,
as a place where you might
lose a lot of your money,
but investors have been kind of moving
into the big tech names as a safe haven
thinking that they're too big to fail
in a matter of speaking
and that's why the NASDAQ
has done so well this year.
The S&P doing pretty well,
about 15% year to date,
but not quite as well.
And then you see on the lower half,
that number that's down
about 20% year to date,
that's those banking stocks.
And even though you did see
news that wasn't as bad as expected,
that wasn't worse than expected,
investors still selling banks,
not buying in yet.
You have not seen Wall Street
change its mind about the big banks
and that's what's there.
So that chart illustrating just the way
that Wall Street has been thinking
about the overall state of the economy,
banks down and out,
tech doing pretty well.
Here's why this week could
be such a big piece of that
or could change that narrative.
We've got a lot of money
flowing into big tech.
A lot of the thinking is,
well, these companies are too big to fail,
but they've also been
announcing a lot of layoffs,
doing a lot of things to kind of patch up
that bottom line, right?
Show that they're making money,
doing what Wall Street wants,
bringing in the dollars.
We are gonna find that if
that actually happened,
did those layoffs actually
create meaningful profits
for these big tech companies?
We are gonna hear from
Microsoft, Alphabet,
Amazon and Meta all this week.
That's gonna tell us a lot
about what the state of the economy is.
Now, Wall Street Journal,
we exclusively reported last week
that Meta CEO, Mark Zuckerberg,
had announced that there
weren't going to promise
no more layoffs.
They've already had huge layoffs
affecting about a quarter of the company
and Mark Zuckerberg saying,
"Ah, we might just have
to do more layoffs."
So keep your eye on those tech earnings.
If that bull falls out of tech,
you could see the stock market overall
move meaningfully lower
and that could be some
negative overall news
for the US economy,
especially as we've seen
layoffs start to pick up here,
as we've seen jobless claims pick up
and all those other things.
Other companies to watch this week,
you got Exxon and Chevron,
the big oil majors here in the US.
Johnson&Johnson, Pfizer, McDonald's,
Verizon, T-Mobile all this week,
as well as Visa and MasterCard,
so watch out for those.
GDP coming in this week,
I wanna put a chart up here on your screen
that just shows you what
we've seen from GDP.
Overall, you see over here
to the right of your screen,
you saw those two negative
quarters of GDP contraction
that we talked about at
the beginning of 2022.
Then GDP picked up getting
back in line with trend.
Expectations are for
GDP to come in under 2%,
for the first quarter, about 1.8%.
This chart is illustrating
the overall long run theme
when you take out those pandemic swings.
2021 was a big year,
but now we are expecting lower growth
and less than 2% growth
this first quarter.
Ernst & Young or EY
Chief Economist Greg Daco
put it this way.
He said, "The economy cap 2022 with pride,
but enters 2023 full of doubts."
I think that's a lot of the worry here.
And if that number comes
in below expectations
or even negative,
again, that's gonna raise a lot of fear
about the US economy.
There are a number of
reasons to be worried
that that GDP figure
could come in negative
even though Atlanta Fed
GDPNow is showing 2.5%,
way up from 0.7% increase expected.
So keep that in mind.
Last chart I want to put
up here on your screen
and we want to put that up right now
to show you consumer confidence.
And this is the the
University of Michigan's
consumer sentiment index.
And as you can see,
it's been moving higher.
That's good news.
It means consumers are feeling
good about the economy.
It's part of why we've
seen spending continue,
but as we are seeing rising
gas prices at the pump,
as we are seeing higher oil prices,
as we are seeing higher housing
costs, will that continue?
And that's gonna be a big
part of the overall theme
that we will see.
Can those things continue?
That chart just illustrating
the overall change
that we have seen in consumer confidence
that had really plummeted and bottomed out
and now we've seen a pickup there.
Conference Board and the
University of Michigan
both released their consumer confidence
and consumer sentiment.
Basically, Conference
Board has a larger sample,
they survey more people,
but the University of Michigan
has more detailed questions.
University of Michigan consumer sentiment
is really, how are you feeling?
What are you thinking about the economy?
How do you feel personally?
Whereas the Conference Board is,
what do you think about business?
How are business conditions doing?
The Conference Board
is better at picking up
on indicators related to the
job market and job security,
while the University of Michigan survey,
much more a measure of pocketbook issues.
How are you doing in your life?
University of Michigan
survey is expected to rise
to 63.5 up from last month.
Conference Board expected to decline.
You'll wanna watch both of those.
Listen, that's gonna do it for us here
on "Market Takes" for this week.
We will be back with you again on Monday,
looking ahead to what you need
to be looking out for that week.
But until then, thank you
so much for being with us.
I am Dion Rabouin,
reporter at the Wall Street Journal
and we will see you next time.